imagine being on the final day of a
cruise heading back into port in miami
you're on vacation on a cruise heading
home yep all of a sudden the ship
unexpectedly turns back and heads back
out to the bahamas sounds great actually
i mean you're supposed to be home and
you go what if you have to go to work so
it happened over the weekend to the
passengers on the crystal symphony who
were forced to extend their vacation the
ship made a u-turn after a u.s judge
ordered it to be seized it's part of a
lawsuit against crystal cruises claiming
millions of dollars in unpaid fuel bills
the boat is now docked in the bahamas
outside of u.s jurisdiction passengers
were ferried from the bahamas to fort
lauderdale florida yesterday after
spending an extra day aboard the ship
listen to this
they've given us nothing
and the information was coming so fast
that it was very hard to digest you know
trying to make plans like everyone
trying to switch their travel around and
most of us didn't have reception because
we were in the middle of the ocean
crystal cruises is suspending operations
through april the company says it's
unable to comment on any pending legal
matters so did the captain just decide
to go the other way because they knew
that they were
that they hadn't had unpaid bills yeah
it's basically like one of those la high
speed chases but you're in the middle of
the water
imagine that conversation hey boss
no no i'm serious the ship just turned
around
you know yeah right now i got to go to
that like thomas i got to go back to the
bahamas i don't know what i don't know
what's going on but for people who
really do have commitments yes it's kind
of a pain it's unfortunate it sounds fun
to go to the bahamas but not if you have
to be home yes yes and they're not sure
how they're going to get home i would
like some footage of how they refuel
these ships they just pull up the dock
and someone you know puts the i know i
always die
and clearly they're not paying it's like
yeah you know like i'll pay you later
right
i got you don't worry about it they got
a mini mart there you pick up some
doritos and get back on board thank you
so much